>> YEAR FRESH START.
2017 WAS A BIG YEAR FOR THE
FIVE.
2018 WILL BE BIGGER.
WE'LL KICK IT OFF WITH YOUR
QUESTIONS.
LET'S BEGIN WITH RICHARD S.
HE WANTS TO KNOW, WHAT IS YOUR
STORY OF THE YEAR.
WHAT YOU THINK?
>> INITIALLY ASKED MOVING TO
9:00 P.M. AND WHAT A GREAT IDEA
TURNED OUT.
DISCONNECT.
IT IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
WHAT PEOPLE ARE FEELING AND HOW
THINGS ARE UNFOLDING.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE FEELING
EMOTIONAL ABOUT EVERYDAY BEING
SO DIFFERENT SOME PEOPLE THINK
IT'S THE END OF THE WORLD, OTHER
THINK IT'S THE GREATEST THING
OTHER FOR.
MEANWHILE WE DIVORCE IS FEELING
FROM ACTION, IT'S A PRETTY GOOD
YEAR, STOCK MARKET IS UP,
UNEMPLOYMENT DOWN, DEREGULATION,
ISIS IS DESTROYED.
A SOLID PART OF THE YEAR VERSUS
>> NO ONE HAS ANY IDEA WHAT'S
GOING ON.
DANA, WHAT IS YOUR BIGGEST
STORY?
>> I THINK THE TURNING BACK OF
ISIS.
IF YOU LOOK IN 2016, WHAT WAS
HAPPENING TO YOUNG WOMEN ACROSS
THE MIDDLE EAST, THESE YOUNG
WOMAN BEING RAPED AND TORTURED,
JUST DISTRACTION AND BECAUSE OF
RULES OF ENGAGEMENT CHANGING AND
OTHER COUNTRIES PITCHING IN TO
HELP, ISIS IS NOT DEAD, BUT
CERTAINLY WITHOUT ITS TERRITORY,
THAT'S PROBABLY THE MOST
CONSEQUENTIAL STORY OF THE YEAR.
>> I WAS GOING TO GO WITH THE
LAUNCH OF THE DAILY BRIEFING.
COME I THINK IT HAS CHANGED SO
MUCH.
IT'S A TUMULTUOUS TIME.
ALSO PEOPLE SAY TO ME MY PEOPLE
ARE OUT THERE LIVING IN CRAZY
TIME, THINGS ARE JUST WILD.
IT'S LIKE A ROLLER COASTER RIDE
JUST TO GO THROUGH LIFE.
SOME PEOPLE SAY THEY CAN EVEN
TAKE THE NEWS.
>> ARE THESE VOICES IN YOUR
HEAD?
>> SOMETIME.
BUT PRESIDENT TRUMPS IN OUR GIRL
WAS HUGE.
THOSE ARE BIG CHANGES.
>> THE POPULARITY OF OBAMA CARE,
I DO NOT SEE THAT COMING.
OVER THERE.
EVERY TIME I TALK TO PEOPLE
ABOUT POLITICS AND WHAT IS GOING
ON IN THE WORLD, THEY TALK ABOUT
THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
IN PEOPLE SAY WOW, I WISH WE HAD
MORE ABOUT THIS.
IT'S A TREMENDOUS TURNAROUND.
SEEN INCREASES IN JOB NUMBERS
AND THINGS MOVING FOR IN A
FORWARD PROGRESSION.
I'M HAPPY ABOUT THAT, ESPECIALLY
FOR THE FAMILIES.
>> THE B LEVEL WOULD BE THE
WEATHER.
WHAT HAPPENED IN HOUSTON IN
PARTICULAR.
REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED IN MIAMI.
>> ALSO, A LOT OF SHOOTINGS.
WE DO NOT HAVE A LOT OF ANSWERS
THERE.
A QUESTION FROM STEVE B.
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION ACHIEVE IN
>> I AM ALMOST TIRED OF WINNING.
WE ALSO HAD WAIT A SECOND,
OVERACHIEVE.
YES, ISIS HAD DEFINITELY BEEN
DECIMATED AND GROUNDS HAD BEEN
MADE AND GAVE.
I AM SO VERY CONCERNED ABOUT AL
QAEDA AND OTHER OFFSHOOTS THAT
ARE REALLY FIGHTING TO TAKE THAT
MANTLE THAT ISIS HELD TRYING TO
PUSH FORWARD IN THE CALIPHATE.
>> I'M CURIOUS.
>> I THINK NUMBER ONE FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE IS THE PRESIDENT
SO THREATENED ABOUT THE IDEA
THAT DOCK I WOULD GO AWAY AND
THEY WOULD BE DEPORTED.
CLICHÉD TERMS.
THEY'RE SO HARD LINE ON
IMMIGRATION THAT IF HE'S ABLE TO
CUT A DEAL COME I THINK HIS BASE
WILL NOT SAY IT'S A BAD DEAL,
THE AMNESTY, THEY MIGHT ACTUALLY
EMBRACE AND SAY GIVE IT A
CHANCE.
>> I WAS GOING TO AGREE WITH YOU
ON IMMIGRATION EXCEPT I SAY I
SEE THE WALL BUILT IN 2018.
LOFTY BUT SUPER IMPORTANT AND
ACHIEVABLE IN A MIDTERM ELECTION
THAT IS, TO EASE THE WAY PEOPLE
TO ADOPT CHILDREN.
I THINK FROM THE FOSTER CARE
PROGRAM THEIR PEOPLE TO TAKE
CARE OF THEM BUT THE WAY TO
ATTRACTION IS QUITE CLUTTERED.
THERE ARE REGULATIONS THAT COULD
CHANGE.
THERE'S THINGS THAT YOU CAN DO
WITHIN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
IMPROVE.
ALSO INTERNATIONAL ADOPTION HAS
THERE ARE AMERICAN COUPLES WHO
WOULD LOVE TO ADOPT CHILDREN
FROM ANYWHERE.
I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP POSSIBLY
WORKING WITH THE FIRST LADY
COULD TURN THAT AROUND.
IT WOULD BE WORTHWHILE.
I THOUGHT HILLARY CLINTON AS
SECRETARY OF STATE WOULD HAVE
DONE SOMETHING MORE IN THAT
REALM BUT SHE NEVER DID.
THIS IS MY OPPORTUNITY THEY CAN
MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
COULD HELP MAKE A LOT OF JOY.
>> GREGG.
>> FAT KIDS.
WE HAVE A LOT OF FIGHT KIDS OUT
>> I LOVE FAT KIDS, I'M BEING
BELIEVE THEY HAVE TO REALLY
FOCUS ON THE MAY TECHNOLOGY.
WE'VE SEEN WHAT HAPPENED WHEN AN
AIRPORT GO STARK, TOTAL PANIC.
IMAGINE IF THAT WAS HAPPENING IN
EVERY CITY.
I KNOW WHAT HE COULD DO THAT
THEY COULD TELL US ABOUT IT.
WE ALSO NEED A PLANT AGAINST THE
ROBOT'S.
THEY ARE COMING.
I AM ON THEIR SIDE.
>> TERROR ROBOTS.
MOVING ON.
QUESTION FROM LINDY.
WHAT IS THE DUMBEST RESOLUTION
YOU HAVE EVER MADE?
LET'S START WITH ONE.
>> I TRIED TO BAN ALL DESSERT, I
THINK IT LASTED THREE MONTHS;
BUT YOU.
>> I THINK I'LL CALL FAKE NEWS
ON THAT.
I ME AFFECTED?
>> MIND WOULD BE ONE TIME I DID
NOT THINK I WOULD EAT SALAMI OR
CURED MEATS.
I LASTED 24 HOURS.
>> I MADE THE RESOLUTION WHILE
WE ARE HERE AND GREGG SAYS, THAT
STUPID, WHY WOULD YOU EVEN TRY
TO DO THAT.
IT WAS TO TRY TO DRINK LESS
WINE.
AND NOT DRINK DURING THE WEEK,
THAT'S NOT LAST.
AND IF YOU MAKE A RESOLUTION YOU
THINK ABOUT IT MORE AND MORE
THINK ABOUT IT THE MORE YOU ON
IT.
>> I AGREE THAT WAS A DUMB
RESOLUTION.
>> MY DUMBEST RESOLUTION WAS
LAST YEAR WHEN I TRY TO QUIT
TO SO MANY PEOPLE THAT I
REALIZE, I CANNOT CHANGE ME.
I CANNOT CHANGE BEING SO SELFISH
AND WILLING TO CHANGE OTHERS.
AND THAT THE INTERVIEW WHEN THEY
SAY WHAT'S YOUR BIGGEST WEAKNESS
SAY WHAT'S YOUR BIGGEST WEAKNES
WEAKNESS.
>> SOME PEOPLE ARE LITTLE
INEBRIATED.
THIS IS FROM VICTORIA E.
WHAT WAS THE BEST YOUR NEW LIFE
AND WHY?
ABOUT THIS ISSUE BECAUSE I
JOINED THE FIVE.
>> THE BEST YEAR MY LIFE?
THESE ARE DIFFICULT.
I'M PRETTY GRATEFUL FOR EVERY
WORD I HAVE HAD.
DEAR MET PETER MOVED TO ENGLAND
AND HAD THAT EXPERIENCE OF BEING
MARRIED IN OVERSEAS WITH THE NEW
PUPPY.
THAT YEAR WAS CRAZY.
WE DECIDED TO LIVE IN SAN DIEGO
BECAUSE WE COULD.
I DIDN'T HAVE A JOB, WE DIDN'T
HAVE A CAR AND WE HAD A PUPPY,
WE DIDN'T EVEN HAVE A BED.
RIGHT NOW IF I LOOKED AT HOW
>> MY BEST WAS WHEN YOU LEFT THE
COUNTRY AS WELL.
>> YOUR KIND OF MOVING MEANS
SOMETIMES.
THE BEST YEAR WAS WHEN -- WAS
BORN, AND EVERYTHING IS SO MUCH
FUN.
I GET VERY EXCITED WHEN I SEE
HIS FACE.
>> I WOULD HAVE TO SAY MY
FAVORITE YEAR WAS 1984, WE
PROVED THE BOOK WAS JUST
GARBAGE.
1984 WAS FINE.
>> IS HARD BECAUSE YOU GET TO BE
A CERTAIN AGE AND THERE'S A LOT
OF YEARS AND TIME GOES FASTER
OTHER DAY.
>> I THINK I TOLD YOU THAT.
YET MORE BEHIND YOU INSTEAD OF
IN FRONT OF YOU.
WHEN YOU'RE CUT KID WHEN YOU'RE
FOUR YEARS OLD ABOUT DATES LIKE
AN ETERNITY.
THE NIGHT BEFORE CHRISTMAS IS
LIKE SEVEN YEARS.
BUT AS YOU GET OLDER IT'S
NOTHING.
I CALCULATED ONE WEEK AT THE AGE
OF 53 IS BASICALLY ONE DAY WHEN
YOU'RE SIX.
>> 'S LAKE SUMMERTIME AND
SNOWFALL.
>> IF YOU COULD ASSUME THE
IDENTITY OF ANOTHER PERSON FOR
2018, WHO WOULD IT BE?
>> MY TWIN BROTHER, GUNTHER.
>> YOU SOMETIMES HEAR WHEN
AMNON.
I THINK I LIKE TO BE THERESA
MAY.
>> ALONG WITH THE ROYALTIES.
>> I COULD BE IN CHARGE.
I COULD BE AT THE WEDDING IN
MAINE, I COULD BE MY OWN
OFFICIAL WORLD CORRESPONDENT.
ALSO, I COULD WORK STRATEGICALLY
WITH UNITED STATES AND WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> ALL THAT SO YOU'RE GETTING
IN.
>> I WILL SAY -- JUST GOT
TREATED LASTER TO THE YANKEES.
LEAGUE'S IN 2017.
NOW HE'S WITH THE YANKEES.
HE HAS A BIG HOME RUN HITTER TO